did you hear that not so long ago a
five-year-old boy went up against 12 of
russia's greatest chess grand masters
and do you know what happened he lost
every single match that's because
winning at chess dear viewers isn't easy
chess is an ancient game of strategy
cunning and skill it's not just about
thinking one step ahead of your opponent
that's not going to be enough make a
wrong prediction and you could end up
sacrificing one of your pieces as well
as vital space on the board but thinking
two to three steps ahead beating your
adversary's moves before they've even
been made now there's a viable strategy
tricky but viable after all if it was
easy we'd all be queen scam gambit level
chess prodigies eric matthews had never
been good at the game but he had a
pretty substantial reason to keep trying
and that reason's name was brian
matthews his father you see for as long
as eric could remember his dad had
regarded a high level of skill on the
chessboard to be a sign of intellectual
superiority intelligence was something
that brian put quite a considerable
value on given that he was a professor
at a university in their home country of
england some of eric's earliest memories
were of playing chess with his dad
usually on a friday night when brian got
home after a week of giving lectures to
the next generation of scholars
obviously with his son at such a young
age the professor would take it easy on
eric playing in a much laxer fashion
focusing instead on teaching the boy the
basics of the game and for a time at
least it was good it was a rare time
that eric and his academic father could
spend bonding after all with his mother
gone his dad was all he had but as the
years passed the game changed by the
time eric was a teenager brian had
stopped pulling his punches on the
chessboard he hoped his son would build
on what he'd learned when they played in
the past using those skills to best his
dad on the board but to eric playing
chess had never been about a purely
educational experience it was more about
spending time with his old man time
after time the young man's pawns fell
prey to brian's expertly considered and
far more competitive moves try as he
might eric couldn't best his dad he
tried his best and never stopped putting
the effort into every game but thinking
too hard about one possible plan of
attack left him wide open to a counter
strategy from the professor over and
over again he landed himself in
checkmate or made illegal moves without
even realizing it every time earning
criticism and chastisement from his
scholarly father every game it got worse
it was like eric could feel his father's
gaze and the weighty expectations behind
it with each move he made across the
board there were so many nights where he
wondered if it would be better to give
up entirely to knock down his own king
and concede but how could he ever find
any other shared interests with his dad
beyond the two of them playing chess it
had become a lifeline tethering father
and son together and to cut it now left
eric uncertain if he'd sink or be able
to swim alongside brian he had long
admired his father his achievements in
academia were impossible to avoid with
more framed certificates hung up on the
walls than there were photos of the pair
of them together but the shadow it cast
over him made eric desperate to keep
this one shred of common ground alive
eric wasn't the type to give up despite
how much of an uphill struggle the
situation felt like taking a leaf out of
his professor father's scholarly ways he
decided to learn the game inside and out
every known move and strategy he would
research the entire history of chess
itself if that's what it took to play
with the same skill as his dear old dad
over the coming weeks eric checked out
every book at his local library on the
subject beginner's guides advance rule
books and even a few volumes on notable
players throughout the extensively long
history of the game along the way a
chapter of a certain book stood out to
eric it described a chess prodigy from
russia who had created an early
mechanical chest device known as the
samurai it had been designed to be a
traveling curiosity and would sit
playing chess games against volunteers
taken from a spectating audience each
one of them having forked over some of
their hard-earned money to watch this
man-made wonder the russian chess
prodigy's young daughters also had a
love for the game seeing that gave eric
a pang of jealousy wondering if those
daughters had as much trouble playing
their own father as he did with brian
but at least there was an underlying
shred of hope there too if this father
and his daughters could bond over chess
maybe there was a chance for eric and
his dad too
sadly it's one thing to try and learn
all the facts you can about chess it's
an entirely different beast to put all
that information to use and apply it to
an actual game despite having read every
book he could get his hands on eric
still couldn't best brian at the board
it was like nothing had changed his
father barely noticed when eric tried to
replicate move sets he'd read up on and
still managed to not only counter those
moves but check his queen in the process
so practice eric thought after all
practice was supposedly meant to make
perfect right the plan was simple if he
practiced his chess moves enough times
and figure out how he could call on what
he'd learned then he might stand a
chance at winning when he and his dad
played each other there was just one
hiccup to this plan eric needed someone
to practice against the only other
person in the house was brian meaning it
was that hiccup that turned into a
problem almost big enough to stop eric
in his tracks that is until he went into
his father's lab it was under the house
itself a sort of
sub level may be used as a basement or
seller by the previous owners but since
professor matthews and his son had lived
there the entire room had been remodeled
into an at-home laboratory not a
terribly advanced one of course this was
the early 90s after all the majority of
brian's time even when he was at home
instead of working at the university was
spent on his own downstairs in the lab
eric had gone down there in search of
his dad to ask him if there was anyone
whom he knew who he could practice and
develop his chess skills with but
instead what he found down there was the
last thing he expected to see not that
he had any clue exactly what it was at
first the thing
was some kind of bizarre contraption a
collection of components that didn't
seem to be in any logical configuration
however it was primarily composed of
something that eric recognized all too
well a chess table this one was metal
steel to be precise and seemed to be
hooked up to some sort of computer while
back in the 90s computers were hardly as
commonplace as they are now eric had
seen a fair few at school and the
library although this one was different
it seemed old far older than eric
thought computers had been around for as
far as he knew they'd only really come
to prominence in the mid-80s but this
computer looked like it predated even
that period noticing another part of the
contraption a large steam engine with
the words manufactured by modslay suns
and field established 1840 engraved on
one side made it seem that this whole
device had been around since the
victorian era the next part that caught
his eyes was the chess pieces themselves
each one standing neatly in its place on
the board they looked delicate
intricately carved from some smooth
substance for a moment eric toyed with a
thought of how they could even be made
from bone noticing how each pawn knight
rook bishop king and queen were all
about the size of a human finger bone he
dismissed the idea nobody would ever do
something like that
eric grabbed a sheet covering a large
component hooked up to the mess lifting
it away in a swift pole it unveiled what
was sitting beneath a full suite of 18th
century samurai armor eric looked closer
at the embellishments on the surface of
the pauldrons he was no expert on feudal
japan but it looked authentic enough to
be the real thing if not a very close
approximation taking a look at the
collection of oddities all tethered
together in his father's lab a certain
detail of all his chess research came to
the forefront of eric's mind the armor
that had given it away
this was the samurai or at the very
least a crude homemade version of it
that his dad had put together but if it
worked it was also something to practice
against it didn't take eric long to
start tinkering with the contraption
trying to get it to work all the while
the question of why his dad owns such a
thing kept drumming up noise in the back
of his head had brian built it or was
this the original made by that russian
chess prodigy was this machine the
reason that eric's dad possessed such an
unbeatable skill at chess and would
using it give him the edge he needed to
best him at the game and earn his
father's respect after what felt like
hours upon hours of trial and error with
a machine he could barely comprehend
eric seemed to have cracked it as far as
he could tell the steam engine powered
the whole contraption and could be set
to five different speeds labeled on the
side in roman numerals the power from
the engine was then fed to some kind of
sophisticated mechanism that was within
the suit of samurai armor allowing it to
move and what appeared to be a series of
electromagnets that moved the chess
pieces and kept them on the board
flicking it onto the third highest of
the five speed levels the machine
whirred into life the sound of creaking
and grinding of metal filled the lab
kneeling opposite eric went to make the
first move only to stop himself it
wasn't that he changed his mind about
practicing against the samurai but
because of the speed he'd set it to
determining that the settings might have
correlated to difficulty levels eric
figured that if he really wanted to get
the most rigorous practice to really
hone his chest moves he needed to commit
fully reaching for the dial he turned
the device up to its fifth and highest
speed then made his first move he pushed
one of the bone-colored prawns forward
by a single square and waited a split
second passed and the arm of the early
automaton responded with its first
counter move it was quick almost moving
with the same natural fluidity and speed
as an actual human being albeit still
with a little bit of creaking and some
slight clockwork-like stutters but it
worked nonetheless the machine could
play the tension over the first game was
palpable forming a layer of sweat over
eric's forehead every whirr and tick of
the machine gave the impression that
they were playing with a stop clock
timing each of their moves adding to the
urgency despite this eric matthews tried
his best to stay calm this was practice
after all a dry run not the inevitable
game he'd play against his dad with
every move he made his heart drummed
against his ribs uncertain he'd made the
right call each time the robotic hand
cruelly knocked over one of his pieces
away eric felt a surge of frustration
but told himself to quell it he kept
focused using what he'd researched to
adapt and respond accordingly to each of
the machines moves until
checkmate he'd beaten it he might have
lost everything save for a knight a rook
his king and queen but he had won
trapped without anywhere else to move on
the board the middle finger of the
automaton conceded the game knocking
over its own king and resignation
panting heart racing from the sheer
excitement of being on the winning side
of a game eric hurley gathered up and
reset all the pieces he had to go again
not just so that he could be certain it
wasn't a fluke but to make sure he had
what it took to take on his professor
father back and forth eric went with the
chest machine over and over again they
were fairly evenly matched it seemed
eric won the second game only to be best
on the next two but it was some time
afterward he had lost count of exactly
how many rounds later but things started
to change maybe it was the age and
condition of the victorian era chess
computer the natural wear and tear
stopping it from functioning properly
but eric noticed that the samurai
started to make moves that were
illogical that practically offered him
the upper hand with no discernible
strategy behind them then its movements
became flat-out illegal disregarding the
directions and number of squares each
different piece was allowed to move
before long it was moving them
erratically around the chessboard
refusing to cooperate and forcing eric
to call an end to the days practicing
unfortunately it wouldn't be the end of
the unusual things that would happen
that day did you send me that weird
email was the first question eric's dad
asked him when he returned home looking
noticeably under the weather confused
eric said that he had no idea what his
father was talking about professor
matthews then went on to describe what
he'd received on his work computer it
had been an email with a file attached
to it named shockmatey a word in russian
that translates to
chess embedded in the email below
although it had taken a long time to
load being opened on a 1990s computer
there had apparently been a photo as
well it was rather odd eric brian went
on quite unnerving to tell the truth
black and white are sort of distorted
and stretched but it looked like two
young girls one grinning and the other
screaming i've been feeling well
not quite myself since i saw it with
that brian excused himself stating that
he'd been suffering from headaches and a
high temperature and as a result needed
to go and lay down it wasn't like his
father to get ill eric thought but of
course he had no reason to assume it was
anything serious probably just a speed
of fatigue after a long day of teaching
at the university no cause for concern
if only that's all it was within a few
hours brian was completely restless so
unable to sleep that simply taking a nap
was impossible he kept calling to eric
complaining of the sound of childlike
laughter coming from somewhere in the
house but his son hadn't heard anything
by the time the sun went down eric was
trying to calm his dad down through a
rush of intense anxiety that gripped him
brian had been claimed to be
hallucinating seeing the warped faces of
two girls that frightened him half to
death it was getting late long past the
time that they usually played chess
together but for now eric's mind was
focused solely on helping his dad for a
while he seemed to be able to calm his
father down only to realize brian wasn't
settled at all he was awake eyes open
fully conscious but wasn't responding at
all to eric asking if he was all right
instead the accomplished academic just
stared blankly into space eric had been
up all night exhausted worried for
brian's safety and completely clueless
about what was happening to him after a
while being non-responsive his dad
seemed to regain a little bit of
lucidity once more but his behavior was
erratic take me back to work i i need to
get on my computer brian demanded of his
son when eric refused that's when his
dad got angry and agitated professor
brian matthews was sadly found dead
within the next few months several
months later as the sole executor of his
father's estate and last living relative
eric had to be the one to go through his
dad's personal belongings volumes upon
volumes of thick academic books his
smart scholarly clothes the house was
almost clear now save for one thing that
was left in the basement lab flicking on
the light switch eric looked at the
samurai sitting motionless still
uncovered after their last practice game
he'd sold off the chess pieces to a
collector in new york now was just an
empty oddity eric placed a king on the
board one of the ones that he and his
dad had used when they played each other
with a gentle flick of his finger
he toppled it resigning to the strange
automaton and leaving it there in the
laboratory he wasn't sure how but he had
some kind of gut feeling that this chess
machine had somehow been responsible for
his father's fate of course eric had no
idea what the device actually was and
what or who
lay beneath its whirring metal parts
scp-1875
is the designation given to this machine
now and has been ever since the
foundation recovered it not long after
eric sold his father's house they were
able to learn much more about it than
young mr matthews or even the late
professor matthews ever had not just how
to make it work or what its function was
but who had built it and who had been
used to build it although details of his
real name eluded the foundation's top
researchers they were able to uncover
newspaper articles about the device from
all over russia america and england
dating back to the early 1990s the
russian chess prodigy who'd invented it
and toured the chess playing machine
around had used some interesting
components to make his automaton maybe
they were what derived its skill at the
game and its apparent temperament when
the device was made to play at maximum
speed for too long he had used his
daughters to make the machine
deep within the heart of this early form
of computer the two girls brain tissue
had been hooked up to the electromagnets
the machine's moves were theirs each
pawn or rook shifting across the black
and white squares of the board every
rule or strategy their prodigy father
had taught it all determined how the
device played their minds taken from
their skulls were now the analytical
engine of their father's creation the
bones of their fingers he'd carved into
chess pieces
over the coming weeks the foundation
naturally ran their usual slew of tests
on scp-1875
playing multiple games of chess against
it every time they increase the
machine's five levels of speed until it
started behaving erratically while on
the highest setting shortly after every
member of personnel working on
scp-1875 received a bizarre email it
contained a file named with the russian
word for chess and a photograph of the
stretched distorted smiling and
screaming faces of two young girls faces
that you might be seeing very soon
now go and check out
scp-1733 season opener and
scp-1984 the dead hand if you're in the
mood for more tales of technological
terrors and other chaos spreading
computerized creatures